what's up guys welcome back to another
hazel devlog
so last week we talked about prefabs and
now
we can shoot them so this was something
that i was working on during the last
week
basically being able to instantiate
prefabs from lc sharpscripts
you can see i put together a little bit
of a scene here where
we can just click and shoot well really
any prefab at the moment
it's this like glowing green like
uranium looking like cube we can even
kind of rock a jump as you saw there by
just aiming it below us
and then firing now i know it might seem
overly bright and emissive but that's
because everyone knows that once you
have bloom and emission inside game
engine
you have to actually use it for pretty
much everything so that's what you're
seeing here
i kind of like this idea of starting off
a devlog with the actual demo so that
way it's really clear to see what i
guess is new and what we're talking
about so let's just spend the rest of
this video
diving in and taking a look at this in a
little bit more
detail as always if you're supporting
hazel on patreon
you can jump into the scene yourself and
try it out okay so i hope you guys
enjoyed that little prefab
demo let's dive in and take a look at
how the scene
was structured so last devlog i
explained what prefabs were i'll have
that linked up there by the way
so i'm not going to really go over that
i just wanted to show you guys the new
features that i've added since last week
basically i put together this little
scene that is uh
pretty standard uh it's actually kind of
based off of that audio demo that's why
they're a
random things flying flying around there
that's all kind of scripted inside c
but basically what we've got inside here
is a prefab that i think is called
projectile and if we take a look at the
projectile prefab here it is up here
so it's just an entity that's made up of
um
a bunch of different components you can
see here that it shows up
as like blue which indicates that it's a
prefab we can add prefabs normally to
scenes as you would expect
but the cool new thing that i've kind of
added is the ability to instantiate it
from say sharp scripts which is what you
saw in that demo
so over here we have uh our kind of
player
entity that has a c-sharp script
attached as well
and you can see that script over here so
this um has a projectile prefab
field which is this particular
projectile and if we take a look at
uh how the c-sharp script is actually
written over here
we have it's very messy but we have a um
where is this we have a prefab a public
prefab called projectile prefab that's
what you saw inside the editor
and then we have this was just me
testing stuff
but we have this update shooting
function which basically has a bit of a
cool down there and it spawns a
projectile if we're ready to shoot
and then what that does is cause
instantiate with that projectile prefab
get is since it's a rigid body we have
to get the rigid body it's a dynamic
rigid body set the rigid body's
translation to be
like where we want it to basically spawn
and then add a force to it
we also actually add a parent and this
parent i think at this point is
this projectile holder entity so if i
run
the um if i run the scene here you'll
see that we have this projectile holder
entity that actually holds all these
it's just a
i guess a bit of a test and more so for
like organization and stuff
but you can see the scene running
through um through hazelnut as well so
that's how the script works
i guess pretty much how you would expect
uh and then this instantiate function is
kind of doing
um most of the work now i want to
quickly mention that like
c-sharp scripts and the way that we kind
of handle these in hazel are
very much like uh i always compare it to
puppet strings because
all we're really doing i mean if you
look at what a prefab is at the moment
inside the script it's just this it is
literally just
a 64-bit asset id it's the id of the
prefab that we want to
instantiate and so when we have a
function such as
instantiate if we take a look at what
instantiate does
it basically it calls the native
function which tries to actually create
it
um we'll we'll go into that in a minute
but but basically
uh all we have to do is pass in we're
passing the id that of this current
entity that is actually instant chaining
another entity just
in case we need it i don't think we're
using it at the moment and then we
actually pass in that prefab id as well
to the native class plus code if that
returns not zero so that can happen if
like the asset doesn't exist for
whatever reason
we return null if it does return zero
otherwise we create a new entity out of
it and again an
entity is just an id as well everything
is just like a uuid which is pretty cool
so that's what the instantiate function
does it calls instantiate native
which if we jump into the c plus plus
code
instantiate native let's just go to that
function directly
that's i it's not actually called
instantiate native i think it's just
called instantiate
and it's inside in oh whoops let's open
file
instantiate it's inside like script
wrapper this is it
so this is what it does it gets the
current scene context
it gets like the map of entities it
checks to see if the prefab id is
actually a valid asset handle and then
if it is
it just retrieves the asset and then
calls scene instantiate which basically
just adds it to like the
the scene as like a special prefab thing
um and then we get back the uuid of the
entity that we've just created
so in terms of like how this is all put
together it's all very basic very simple
that's the way i like it um and then
since everything is a uuid when we get
that back as an entity we can do
whatever we want
to it which uh you know such as set that
translation of like a particular
component that we retrieve
out of force to it to it to actually
make it shoot
all of that kind of good stuff so that's
kind of a look at
the code behind this demo now in terms
of the ui
the cool thing about prefabs is that
it's really easy to make something new
and then kind of i guess
replace the existing functionality with
that new asset
so what i mean is if we were to like
create like a sphere for example
let's just say we wanted to make it
shoot a sphere instead so what i can do
is create this sphere maybe i'll make it
a bit smaller over here
let's go ahead and add our like rigid
body component to it
we'll make it dynamic i might decrease
the mass
we'll add a sphere collider component to
it
which is oh right it already has one
because i created a sphere
let's add a physics material to it such
as like this projectile material which
is
uh which we can add a little bit of
bounciness to so let's go ahead and drag
that
into here and what am i what else am i
missing anything i've decreased the mass
no that looks pretty good to me oh yeah
well let's add some other stuff like a
material
and we'll also add a light to it so i'll
come over here and by the way you can
create like sub entities i guess like as
in
i can i can add children to this if i
want um
but i'm not going to but it works trust
me so
let's make the radius like a bit smaller
maybe we'll make it red and actually
let's make like a nice red material
maybe i'll up the intensity as well so
if i go into like my materials
let's make this material called red
sphere
um we'll drag that into here we'll
double click on it to edit it which
opens up the material editor which i'll
put over here
we'll make it red we'll add some
emission
to it because everything has to be
emissive as you know um
i might decrease the intensity of
skylight because i think it's
getting a little bit bright in here um
okay and now i've got this sphere so how
do i make a prefab out of it well i can
just drag it over here
and call it like sphere i can't even see
what i'm typing
sphere right and then uh now that's a
prefab i can delete this i can drag it
in and you can see it is in fact a
prefab and it's
the same way as what we left it but then
if i go into player i can just drag that
sphere now into here
to replace the projectile so now if i
hit play and shoot
you can see we're shooting these kind of
red spheres so it's pretty cool because
it means that you can
like just completely uh kind of
you know separate certain functionality
and scripts
and kind of certain assets i guess uh
from the actual code and from the actual
c sharp scripts
um which is really cool because again
someone you know
instead of a sphere this could be like a
rocket and some artists could be working
on that rocket perfecting it making it
perfect
and meanwhile another programmer could
be like doing the
or a program i could be doing the actual
like game functionality and it could be
using this placeholder sphere
but then when the rocket's made you can
just replace the rocket or
replace the sphere with that rocket and
everything everything's ready to go
so um yeah i think prefabs are really
cool i
like obviously they're really cool and
we love using them
in whatever engine we're working in but
it's one of those things that i didn't
really think about too much when i was
designing hazel and when i was creating
like the
kind of rest of the engine but you know
now that we have
um now that we're actually beginning to
make games with hazel
having having that technology and having
those kinds of kinds of things
that's why it's so important to make
games with game engines because there's
so many features that
might not even pop into your head that
are so so so important
and if you're making a game then you're
kind of going through that entire list
of
of features that you might want and
actually adding stuff that makes your
life way way way easier
anyway if you guys enjoyed this little
dev vlog don't forget to hit the like
button if you did
patreon.com best way to help support
hazel and get access to all the source
code and play around with it and learn
from it
we have a fantastic learning community
and i've got some pretty exciting
uh content on like the educational side
of things coming as well but let me know
what you thought of this dev vlog i
showed a little bit more code than usual
i do have some deep dives planned uh
very soon i'm working currently working
on the bloom one
so how bloom works in game engines and
inside hazel as well and that's going to
be like an actual deep dive but if you
if you have any other topics that you
want me to
kind of do a deep dive video in then
please let me know in the comment
section below
and i will see you guys next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you